A time to eat, drink and be merry would refer to as Mardi Gras,...
...which is French for "Fat Tuesday".
It refers to the practice of the last night of eating rich or fatty foods...
...before the ritual fasting of Lent.
Popular practices that associate with Mardi Gras includes wearing masks and costumes,...
...dancing, sports competitions, parades, throwing beads.
That's why we're here, the beads and the trinkets.
According to the Los Angeles Times, an estimated 25 million pounds of plastic beads...
...make their way through The Big Easy every Mardi Gras.
And because they can't be processed by local recyclers,...
...they often end up as litter or in the landfills.
Some New Orleans-based non-profits, like the Arc of Greater New Orleans...
...have taken it upon themselves to gather up the discarded baubles...
...and resell them for further use during Carnival season and other celebrations.
You could donate the appropriate beads to recycling bead drives...
...or to local preschool or daycare centers for their dress up and arts and crafts time.
Make coasters and hot plates or a mural.
Stephan Wanger completed the world's largest mosaic ever made out of beads,...
...over a million to be correct.